It's the beginning of the lecture,
but how do,
how does morality from
stronger and weaker to what's good and
what is it?
Well,
I think it depends to some degree on
what you mean by stronger.
So physical strength is one element and
like if you look at mythological heroes,
imagine that the stories of heroes are
fragmented elements of,
uh,
of the archetype.
And so one kind of archetypal hero
obviously as someone who's physically
strong,
you know,
you see that there's a great movie that
you could watch about this.
It's called Hitman Hart.
It's one of the best documentaries I've
ever seen and it's about this guy named
Bret Harte.
Bret Harte was for awhile,
the most famous Canadian on the planet,
and he was a worldwide wrestling
foundation,
I think.
What did they call that?
Wwf?
Yeah,
he was there,
like lead good guy.
And so he and wrestling,
I love the documentary because when I
was a little kid,
like four or five,
I used to watch his father whose name
was Stu Hart,
who ran this channel,
this wrestling confederation in Alberta.
And Stu Hart had I think eight boys and
he trained all of them to be pro
wrestlers and part of the movie is
extraordinarily funny because Stu Hart
is in it and he's really old.
He's like 85 and he's just barely.
Can you imagine?
He was like a pro wrestler for 40 years,
like every joint is broken and he still
big but he's just barely moving and this
is this kid and another kid come over
and I'm.
Stu is telling the story about how it
used to take his boys into the basement
and toughen them up.
And I think Brett called that the
journey to pain or something like that.
His father would take all these kids
down there and wrestle with them and
push them right to the edge of their
pain tolerance constantly.
And so.
And anyways,
they grew up tough.
There's no doubt about that.
And all his daughters married pro
wrestlers to.
And I think he had seven daughters.
So he's quite the character anyways.
These two kids,
they're like their late adolescence,
early adulthood come over and one of
them's pretty damn cocky and he's
listening to Stewart.
He says something smart like,
well,
you know,
you were pretty,
you were pretty tough with the old days.
Hey,
and stew looks at them and says,
well,
why?
Why don't you come down to the basement
with me?
And he says,
look,
I don't want to hurt you old man.
And so,
so they're filmmakers follow them into
the basement day and like they're kind
of standing there and the old guy grabs
him in a headlock.
It takes him like,
he's like a snake,
a,
he's got her in a headlock like so fast
that the kid doesn't know what to do.
And then.
So stew,
like,
who knows how to put a headlock on
someone.
He's flexing his,
his uh,
his,
his forearm.
Yeah.
Which is still not so bad.
A forearm and he's got this guy's face
is just,
he's just,
he's like,
he's stepped in a bear trap.
Plus he's absolutely shocked that this
old guy got him.
And so he's kind of gasping and stu says
something like,
you watch,
if I flex this just right,
and you can see this vein on his
forehead start to pop out.
It's extraordinarily funny.
Anyways,
Bret Hart plays out the good guy
archetype and Brett's like,
he's a solid guy,
but he's,
I would say he's not particularly
sophisticated and I'm not being cruel
about that.
I mean he had a great career and he's
tough as a boot and so good for him,
but he plays out this,
this good guy archetype and he gets
tangled up in it.
And now I don't remember your damn
question,
but I am trying to answer it.
Tell me the question again.
Oh yes,
yes.
Okay.
Exactly.
Well,
so one of the things I really liked
about this movie was it showed me why
people watched wrestling and I couldn't,
I couldn't because certainly they're not
appealing and I'm not being.
There are different strata of conception
of abstraction that any entertainment
process has to appeal to.
And you know,
most people don't go to movies and
that's actually because it really is
because movies operate at a level of
sophistication that are too high,
that is too high for many people just
like novels.
I mean hardly anyone reads,
you know,
and if you about 15 percent of the
population might be 20 percent cannot
read well enough to follow written
instructions and so and,
and they and people who are,
maybe it's 15 percent of the population
or 10 percent have never finished a
book,
never.
And so,
and it is that high,
but,
but you still,
you're still,
the archetypes still needs to manifest
itself at different levels and so it
manifests itself in wrestling,
but even there where it is physical
force,
it's not just physical force,
like it's a drama between good and evil
and you can see this so clearly and in
the Bret Hart documentary,
because he's the good guy and you know,
the bad guys are really over the top
bad.
It's a real drama.
It's like it's good versus evil in the
rain every time.
And hopefully good winds but good often
gets,
you know,
maybe the bad wrestler brings two of his
friends in and they bring in chairs and
they bashed the hell out of the good
guy.
And the whole audience is just outraged
by this.
And and the documentary does a lovely
job of showing that,
but so even at the level of physical
combat,
let's say you can't reduce what's good
to what strong is just one element of it
better to be strong than to be weak and
so you can have a strong hero because
it's better to be strong than to be
weak,
but it's better to be strong and kind
than to be strong and it's better to be
strong and kind and wise than to be
strong and kind and so.
And that's true not only for human
beings but it's even true,
let's say at the wolf for the chimpanzee
level because one of the things you see
with the chimp dominance hierarchies if,
and I think I mentioned this before,
is if the leader,
the dominant male is really good at
fostering social relations and being
reciprocal in acts like grooming and
also paying attention to the females and
their offspring.
His dynasty will be much more stable and
so strong might be good for one battle.
It might be good for two battles,
but for 50 battles it's not optimized.
Especially because no law,
no matter how strong you are,
someone can take you out,
so,
so what happens is the idea of what's
ideal becomes increasingly complex
across time,
multifaceted,
right,
and so strength,
wisdom,
intelligence,
vision,
all these things are amalgamated into a
single ba and we'll talk a lot about
that because I want to show you how that
happened in Mesopotamia because that's
one of the first places where we have
documentation about how that ideally
merged.
They have a god called Marduk and Martin
had 50 names and as far as I can tell,
the reason for that was that mark was an
amalgam of the tribal Dante's of at
least 50 tribes and and when the within
tribes were brought together and
civilized,
each of their gods who were ideals had
to be amalgamated into something that
was a single,
a single dramatized representation of
value.
Or there was no way that all those
people could have lived together.
Right?
There are different value structures
would have fragmented them and they
would have stayed in a state of war.
And so the question is,
what's the question you're asking?
If it's not strength than what is it?
Well,
it's strength is an element,
but the Egyptians figured out that it
was.
Vision is actually the capacity to pay
attention.
That was paramount and the Mesopotamians
have that figured out more or less too,
because they're god.
Marduk had eyes all the way around his
head.
He could see everywhere.
So seeing was a critical element of what
should be on top.
And the other thing for the
Mesopotamians was the ability to speak.
So by the time of Mesopotamia,
people that already dramatized the idea
that the cardinal human attributes,
our vision and the ability to speak so
and not be the ability to speak the
truth,
to not just speak so.